people
good morning John so last week I watched
a movie called Puss in Boots the last
wish which is a weird movie because it
is about a YouTuber who gets cancer and
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking Hank no that's a movie about a
cat who has boots but hear me out so
there's this cat and he's a performer an
Entertainer he is loved by his whole
entire town he uses his Charisma to
redistribute money to communities that
need it the most and ultimately maybe he
over invests in managing how he is
perceived by a large group of people who
don't actually know him that well and
maybe he under invests in deeper
relationships on the outside he seems
motivated by having a good time but
maybe deeper down he's actually more
motivated by fear fear of being hurt
fear of being perceived negatively fear
of losing his status and now I gotta
take a little bit of a side quest here
and tell you that while cancer is
currently named after crabs which is
weird in the medieval period normal
folks would call cancer simply the wolf
and who is the absolutely unnecessarily
scary villain in Puss and Boots The Last
Wish no I'm not talking about Big Jack
Horner who yes is an antagonist and yes
is unnecessarily scary no the True
Villain is obviously the wolf so one day
Puss in Boots is having just an amazing
time but then he loses the eighth of his
Nine Lives I don't know I never count it
I am not really a math guy and then this
bounty hunter simply appears and this
isn't The Great Gatsby they're not
trying to cover it up they do eventually
just come out and say it don't mean it
metaphorically or rhetorically or
poetically or theoretically or any other
fancy way I'm deaf but they didn't have
to like he fights with two sickles and
they each have eight little kitties on
them with an X scratched through them
the wolf is death the cat is the
screenwriter and Puss in Boots finds
that he has always been able to fight
anyone and has no fear now runs away
terrified of we think and he thinks
the smell of fear but is it death that
he is afraid of or is it something else
you gotta wait to find out so Puss and
Boots runs away and he begins to form
accidentally a little family there's a
romantic interest who's named Kitty Soft
Paws I have a romantic interest her name
is Catherine and her hands are soft and
they kind of adopt a son who's a
terrible looking Chihuahua with a heart
of gold and I have a son who isn't
terrible looking he's actually very cute
and he has a heart of you know it he's
six he's working on it so as Puss in
Boots develops these relationships it
starts to become clear that what he's
afraid of Isn't So Much Death it's his
own fear of death puss really freaks out
not when confronted by death but when he
starts to feel afraid that's why he left
Kitty Soft Paws at the altar I run away
enter oh
oh oh and it's why him running away is
always preceded by his fur beginning to
stand on end he's not running away from
Death he's running away from his fear of
death not to get too deep into spoilers
here I promise there's lots of amazing
stuff I'm moving out and it is on
Netflix right now he develops ways of
dealing with his fear which includes get
this deeper relationships with his new
family and then he is confronted by all
of his former lives and all of the
things that he's done and loved doing in
the past but that didn't have the depth
of the ways that he feels appreciated
and loved by his family and his former
selves well they are appalled to see him
turn away from them but he wants to you
guys have jerks very conflicting for me
in the end Puss in Boots ends up afraid
of death but not afraid of his fear this
anxiety stops piling and piling and
piling on top of him and in that moment
the cat the YouTuber is able to fight
the wolf death while knowing that there
is no way to ultimately defeat it if you
beat Death this time you will be
fighting death again but he's gonna keep
fighting as much as he can for as long
as he can because it's not about looking
good for the crowd it's about preserving
what he loves which is time with his
family and his friends and when he wins
the particular fight with death that he
has at the end of the movie he
recognizes that there is another day
coming when he will not you know we will
meet again right
see Hasta la Muerte
and none of that means that Puss in
Boots doesn't want to continue doing big
interesting amazing adventurous things
he still loves that stuff he loves to
make things for people but knowing that
the next fight with death could happen
at any time and may indeed be the last
one gives him A New Perspective and he
realizes that he both needs and wants
more than he had in all of his former
lives look I don't know why you make a
kids movie that's definitely about
coming to terms with your mortality as a
middle-aged professional Entertainer but
I'm glad they did John I finally found
my Penguins of Madagascar I'll see you
on Tuesday